so we want to evaluate the definite
integral from negative 1 to 2 from
negative 1 to negative 2 of 16 minus X
to the third over X to the third DX now
at first this might seem daunting I have
this rational expression I have X's in
the numerators and X's in the
denominators but we just have to
remember we said to do some algebraic
manipulation and this is going to seem a
lot more tractable this is the same
thing as the definite integral from
negative 1 to negative 2 of 16 over X to
the 3rd minus X to the 3rd over X to the
3rd minus X to the 3rd over X to the 3rd
DX and now what is that going to be
equal to that is going to be equal to
the definite integral from negative 1 to
negative 2 of I could write this first
term right over here let me do this in a
different color I could write I could
write this as 16 X to the negative 3 X
to the negative 3 and this second one we
have minus X to the 3rd over X to the
3rd well X to the 3rd is just over X to
the 3rd over X to the 3rd is just going
to be equal to 1 so this is going to be
minus 1 DX so DX and so what is this
going to be equal to well let's take the
antiderivative of each of these parts
and then we're going to have to evaluate
them at the different bounds so let's
see the antiderivative of 16 X to the
negative 3 we're just going to do the
power rule for derivatives in Reverse
you could do this as the power rule of
integration 4 or power rule of taking
the antiderivative where what you do is
you're going to increase our exponent by
1 so you already know from negative 3 to
negative 2 and then you're going to
divide by that amount by negative 2 so
it's going to be 16 divided by negative
2 times X to the negative 2 all I did is
I increase the exponent and I divided by
that amount so that's the antiderivative
here and 16 divided by negative 2 that
is just negative 8 so we have negative 8
X to the negative 2 and then
the antiderivative of negative one well
that's just negative x negative negative
x negative x and actually you could you
might just know that and hey if I take
the derivative of negative x I get
negative 1 or if you view this as
negative X to the 0 power because that's
what 1 is well it's the same thing you
increase the exponent by 1 to get X to
the first power and then you divide by 1
and so I mean you could view it as that
right over there
but either way you get to negative or
minus X and so now we want to evaluate
that we're going to evaluate that at the
bounds and take the difference so we're
going to evaluate that at negative 2 and
then subtract from that this evaluated
at negative 1 and let me do those in two
different colors so we can see what's
going on so we're going to evaluate it
at negative 2 and we're going to
evaluate it at negative 1 so let's first
evaluate it at negative 2 so this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to when you evaluate it at
negative 2 it's going to be negative 8
negative 8 times X to the negative 2 so
negative 2 to the negative 2 power minus
negative 2 and from that we're going to
subtract it evaluated at negative 1
so it's going to be negative 8 times
negative 1 to the negative 2 power minus
negative 1 all right so what is this
going to be so negative 2 to the
negative 2 so negative 2 to the negative
2 is equal to 1 over negative 2 squared
which is equal to 1/4 so this is equal
to positive 1/4 but then negative 8
times positive 1/4 is going to be equal
to negative 2 and then we have negative
2 minus negative 2 so that's negative 2
plus 2 and so this everything I've just
done in this purplish color that is just
going to be zero and then if we look at
what's going on in the orange
revaluated negative one let's see
negative one to the negative 2 power
well that's 1 over negative 1 squared
well this is all just going to be 1 and
so we're going to have negative 8 plus 1
which is equal to which is equal to
negative 7 so all of this evaluates to
negative 7 but remember we're
subtracting negative 7 and so this is
going to result we deserve a little bit
of a drumroll this is going to be equal
to positive positive 7 and obviously we
don't have to write that positive out
front I just wrote that just to
emphasize that this is going to be a
positive 7